I view one of the big myths of the
crisis as that it was it was purely the
effect of free markets this is what
happens when you have free markets one
of a president's most important
appointments as chairman of the Federal
Reserve the Fed is the symbol of the
integrity of our financial system the
Fed kept interest rates too low for too
long all of you have what degree of
confidence in your ability to control
this hundred percent how can the dollar
be anything except the world's greatest
monetary brethren the coca-cola of money
how could it be anything else well you
just watch hi I'm Zack Weiss Muller with
the reason TV we're here with Jim Bruce
he is the filmmaker behind the new
documentary money for nothing inside the
Federal Reserve which is now being
screened in select theaters and
available on DVD and for digital
download at money for nothing the movie
org you run through the history of the
Federal Reserve a little bit at the
beginning of the movie and what struck
me was that every Fed Chairman kind of
thinks that he's figured it out he's
figured out the formula and the
depression they were too tight and it
caused it to get worse in the 70s it was
too loose Volcker came in then and
tightened it up and then Greenspan was
like inflating and deflating bubbles
like crazy do you think that they are
learning from history and they're
getting better or is that just kind of
an intellectual conceit and hubris if
you look at the Fed they have learned
throughout history but often only after
causing these massive problems problems
like the Great Depression one of our
points in the film is that the Fed might
not have learned the lesson of for
example the 2008 crisis which to some
observers is that cheap money and cheap
credit and a central bank kind of
encouraging and pushing people to take
risk you know different areas of the
market you know is actually something
that's going to hurt our economy make it
less efficient in the long run but the
Federal Reserve story is that we were on
the brink of a financial meltdown and
that they saved the day
and they had to act in the ways that
they acted do you buy that yeah I mean
we try to credit the Fed in the
beginning of the film with the fact that
they did in my opinion and certainly in
their opinion prevent a total collapse
of the financial system in 2008 and
early 2009 I think the Fed was really
the only institution capable of doing
that because they had the ability to
create as much money as they wanted they
weren't constrained in the way Congress
might have been but you could argue that
what they've done since then is pump
lots and lots of money back into this
bloated sort of dysfunctional
inefficient financial system at a time
when the market was really trying to
shrink the financial system you could
argue that they saved the financial
system but you could also argue and I
think you do argue that they pushed us
to the brink of the collapse of the
financial system and a lot of that blame
in your movie seems to rest on a man
named Alan Greenspan and I'm interested
in talking about him because
libertarians have a very contentious
relationship with Greenspan because he
was supposedly an iron Rand acolyte yet
he was kind of the ultimate central
planner you portray him in the movie as
this guy it's kind of like mad genius
pulling levers and pushing buttons and
tweaking the economy just so and until
it just kind of rolls out of control how
does that happen
how do we get an Alan Greenspan who says
that he believes one thing but then
becomes kind of the antithesis of what
he says I mean that's to me as a
filmmaker greens been such a fascinating
character because he totally is it he's
a living contradiction right he was not
a less a fair Fed Chairman he was a guy
who believed in intervening at all these
different points I view one of the big
myths of the crisis as that it was it
was purely the effect of free markets
this is what happens when you have free
markets they do these crazy things the
Fed is really arguably the most
important influence on the stock market
they're printing 500 billion dollars a
year to buy mortgages and 500 billion
dollars a year to buy government debt I
want to talk about the stock market for
a second because you point out that
there's this kind of pernicious myth if
the stock market is good the economy is
good
and that may not be true it's something
we hear all the time from Fed Chairman
President Obama is always bragging about
how well the Dow is doing I really think
it started with Greenspan but Bernanke
has taken it even to a new level in
terms of being very explicit about the
feds role in supporting or propping up
the stock market and touting the
benefits of that and Bernanke and
interviews has actually mistakenly
answered you know someone asked him how
is QE helped the economy and his answer
was well the S&P 500 is up 20% and the
roughly 2,000 is up 30% so he's
literally if someone's asking how's the
economy doing he's people believe that
though they feel good when the stock
market's doing well they're making money
if their money's in the stock market why
isn't it accurate to say that I mean I
think yes socially somehow we have
gotten to this point of view you hear
about on the radio you see about on TV I
think the average American has a sense
that somehow if the stock market's up
it's gonna help them out but what we
point out in the film is that it's
really only the wealthiest Americans who
own a huge portion of the stock market
it's easier to get the stock market to
go up by having really cheap money and
having Ben Bernanke go out and say I
want the stock market to go up with my
policies which he's been doing than it
is to generate actual economic growth to
me it's a big question in the film is is
this what we want this incredibly
powerful institution to do in our name
to prop up the stock in housing markets
or do we want them to allow our economy
to develop in a more healthy and
sustainable way there's a long shot in
your movie of a Ron Paul rally where a
bunch of people are chanting end the Fed
Ron Paul is undeniably the person who's
brought the Federal Reserve into the
consciousness of a new generation yeah
how do you feel about just the idea of
ending the Fed is is it the most prudent
thing to do after it's been at the
center of screw-up after screw-up or is
there some way to just fix it in the
film we sort of we don't go that far
whether you like them or not the Fed is
playing such a huge role in our economy
that it's very hard to imagine how you
would simply just logistically get rid
of the Fed
and and and not sort of totally disabled
or a financial system what we argue in
the film is for something that might be
a little more practically achievable
maybe the Fed should have a single
mandate maybe we shouldn't ask the Fed
to create employment so it seems like
you could say that well if the Fed just
acted more responsibly if they acted
like they did during the volcker years
or something then maybe we'd be ok
but how do you stop these ambitious
people from getting in there and
expanding expanding the mandate the
leadership at the Fed Ben Bernanke and I
think Janet Yellen who's gonna follow
him you know they really believe in the
feds power to to create more growth and
to try to drive us towards full
employment that's what they think
they're doing but yet as we point out in
the film there's other officials at the
Fed who don't think that's possible and
are even giving speeches Charles plosser
was in the film gave a speech very
recently saying he thinks the Fed should
have a single mandate
you mentioned Janet Yellen who's in your
movie she's going to be our next Fed
chair and she didn't know that at the
time that she did the interview so maybe
she was more forthcoming with you what
did what was your impression talking to
her is is there a reason for optimism or
is she pretty much gonna continue in the
Bernanke
let's keep interest rates low and keep
that printing press running type of
model I'm concerned that that genuine is
gonna follow the policies of Ben
Bernanke and so they're really it's
gonna be just more of the same I think
she really has all the intentions he
want I think she wants to help the
average person but I think her idea is
that as that more quantitative easing a
longer period of 0% interest rates is
going to do that I read an article that
said you saw the financial crisis coming
and he put your money where your mouth
was and you bet against that you made a
bunch of money and he used that money to
fund this movie first of all is that
true and if that is true what do you see
next in your crystal ball there were a
lot of people warning about the problems
in the early to mid 2000s and the
housing and financial markets and so I
was reading those people and began
investing accordingly especially in 2007
and 2008 and I did I did profit from a
financial crisis by very aggressive
shorting financial stocks to me that's
the perspective I bring I bring to the
film my concern is that the Fed policies
you know today are gonna backfire just
like they did previously and and there
isn't the ability for the the Fed and
the US government to come in and sort of
save the day because the Fed and the US
government are both really extended
right now and so one of the reasons I
made the film was to really call
people's attention to the risk of
today's Fed policies you know kind of
before we have another crisis in or
worse off for it well it's a very
interesting informative film and I
appreciate you coming here to talk to us
today for reason TV I'm Zak why simile
you